so Donald Trump has become completely
obsessed with Democratic presidential
candidate Michael Bloomberg and it's
starting to get weird and we've been
covering this for a little bit for the
last several weeks Donald Trump has
seemed sort of triggered by Michael
Bloomberg Michael Bloomberg putting out
an ad about Trump's golfing in which he
used some unflattering pictures of
Donald Trump Donald Trump looking obese
in the pictures that Michael Bloomberg's
ad used and Trump very much didn't like
it and the last 24 hours have seen
Donald Trump to vote other than time
devoted to pardoning people convicted of
various types of corruption Trump has
devoted a lot of the last 24 hours to
tweeting and sharing videos and doctored
images of Michael Bloomberg his Twitter
feed is simply riddled with the stuff
and Trump is becoming privately obsessed
with Michael Bloomberg Michael Bloomberg
of course will be debating tonight his
first debate in the Democratic primary
and we will see whether the the stop and
frisk stuff comes up or the leaked or
publicized audio we don't know but what
is very clear is that Donald Trump is
extremely distraught and obsessed with
Michael Bloomberg this started yesterday
with another one of his mini Mike
Bloomberg rants where Donald Trump said
quote what mini Mike is doing is nothing
less than a large-scale illegal campaign
contribution he is spreading money all
over the place
only to have recipients of his cash
payments many former opponents happily
joining or supporting his campaign isn't
that called a payoff mini is illegally
buying the Democrat nomination they are
taking it away from Bernie again mini
Mike major party nominations are not for
sale good luck in the debate tomorrow
night and remember no standing on boxes
the standing on boxes thing is funny but
consider the hypocrisy here that when
Donald Trump ran in 2016
Trump bragged about how he was funding
his own campaign he was rich he's got
money he's finding his own campaign so
he's immune from the demands of donors
and now Michael Bloomberg is funding his
own campaign and Trump says it's illegal
you can be for or against the system of
campaign finance that we have I'm
against it vociferous Lee so
but Donald Trump is criticizing Michael
Bloomberg for doing exactly the same
thing that he did in 2016 the difference
is Bloomberg has way more money that's
quite frankly the the real difference
between Trump and Bloomberg and it seems
to be very triggering to Donald Trump
now after this Michael Bloomberg tweeted
to Trump why do you want to run against
Bernie so badly to which Donald Trump
replied many Mike no I would rather run
against you at this point Trump switched
from tweeting words about Mike Bloomberg
to retweeting doctored images and fake
videos of Bloomberg this is the
president and he's spending his day
retweeting memes and videos of a
possible upcoming political opponent
starting by retweeting a picture of
Michael Bloomberg's head photoshopped
onto a little kids body on a debate
stage next to all the other candidates
again going on this idea that Michael
Bloomberg is is short and then slightly
later in the day retweeting a video of
Michael Bloomberg doctored to look like
Bloomberg isn't tall enough to see over
a lectern while speaking in public
somewhere unclear if Trump is realized
that this was a doctored video I don't
know that they actually care why do you
think that Trump has become so obsessed
with Michael Bloomberg is it that
Bloomberg is so much richer than Donald
Trump is it that Bloomberg is actually
spending his own money and his ad spend
is pushing Trump to have to think about
spending way more than he wants to and
probably isn't actually interested in
doing is it a New York rivalry Bloomberg
and Trump Trump the New York businessman
a Bloomberg the former New York City
Mayor is it that Bloomberg is more
successful as a businessperson than
Trump and doesn't have the multiple
bankruptcies I don't know what the
answer is I'm not a Bloomberg supporter
I'm not defending Bloomberg in any way
but what I want to understand understand
is why is it that Donald Trump Trump has
become obsessed with Michael Bloomberg
triggered by every new ad that Michael
Bloomberg puts out there and focused so
heavily on Michael Bloomberg let me know
what you think I'm thinking out loud
here
I don't know the answer but I want to
hear from you if you watch the David
Pakman show you should check out a
YouTube channel we're partnering with
called up flip click the link right
underneath this video it'll take you to
their channel while you're there make
sure to subscribe and click that bell
for notifications up flip is the channel
perfect for anyone like me who's
fascinated with small businesses and
entrepreneurs and what makes them tick
and every Wednesday up flip uploads a
new video where they interview an
entrepreneur they give you an inside
look at how the business works what
makes the business successful what a day
in their shoes is really like if you
enjoy shows like Shark Tank I think
you'll really like this channel and
again the channel is called up flip
they're friends of the David Pakman show
I'd love it if people in my audience
subscribe to their channel click the
bell so that you get updates about their
videos and I've put a link right below
that will take you directly to their
YouTube channel check it out